el ministro colombiano del interior dice
que las personas muertas en lo que va
del año de ellas 16 tenían orden de
captura que tan cierta es esa hipótesis
del gobierno colombiano que los muertos
son miembros de los grupos armados y no
civiles
muchas gracias por la invitación en este
caso tengo una afirmación un poco
temeraria en el sentido de que si bien
cualquier ciudadano que haya cometido un
delito y haya pagado por él puede tener
antecedentes automáticamente no lo
convierte en sospechoso de haber
cometido otro delito y la obligación del
estado colombiano es velar por la
integridad y el cuidado de los bienes de
todos los ciudadanos con los días
independientes de sus antecedentes por
otro lado es necesario entender que la
guerra que se está librando en arauca
que es el departamento limítrofe entre
colombia y venezuela en una guerra que
ya estuvo como una especie de primer
momento a mediados de la primera década
de este siglo y que hoy por hoy se
desarrolla no sólo en suelo colombiano
sino también en el estado con estaríamos
hablando de un conflicto binacional en
el cual hay unos actores regulares y
otros irregulares que existen conectando
a lado y lado de la frontera sí y a
propósito de ese conflicto binacional
del que usted nos habla cómo es la
situación de violencia del lado
venezolano a propósito de los fallecidos
por las minas antipersona bueno lo que
estamos viendo es que en el lado
venezolano hay un conflicto en el cual
se están enfrentando de manera directa
los actores armados en este caso tenemos
en un bando al gobierno venezolano junto
con el l en atacando o enfrentándose a
un grupo de rearmado del que fue el
antiguo frente décimo de las farc y en
el lado colombiano lo que estamos viendo
es una guerra de muy baja intensidad en
el cual no hay enfrentamiento directo
entre las entre los grupos armados sino
que están atacando a lo que considera
son las bases sociales de su
contradictor y en este caso lo que
estamos viendo es un impacto aún más
humanitario importante no sólo por la
muerte de civiles sino también por el
desplazamiento masivo de cientos
de personas del departamento de la banca
y muy brevemente ha empeorado el
conflicto en la frontera o no
claro que es cuadrado lo que pasa es que
no podemos ver la frontera con
territorio homogéneo lo que en ese
sector de ar aunque sería el sector sur
de la frontera y hay una particularidad
propia porque la guerra se está librando
porque las disidencias de farc quieren
establecer economías vincular con la
coca y ln nos ha dejado porque lln ahí
desarrolló un sistema de tributación que
se basa en la extorsión de las empresas
petroleras y también de las
administraciones locales distinto lo que
pasa en norte de santander cada tumba
donde si hay una dinámica muy ligada a
la exportación y siembra el blondín hato
de coca